[Musique]
sur le parvis du conseil départemental
du haut rhin un bus où les passants
peuvent venir faire tester leur glycémie
l'examen dure à peine quelques minutes
une piqûre au bout du doigt
puis la goutte de sang est analysée
grâce à cet appareil le taux de sucre
dans le sang permet de détecter
d'éventuels problèmes de diabète et
d'orienter les personnes vers un médecin
qui pourra réaliser des analyses plus
complète en vue d'un diagnostic
définitif
c'est juste à côté de mon travail et ça
me permet de me tranquillise et sur mon
état de santé y est en quelque sorte je
suis en surpoids est également j'atteins
mes 50 ans donc c'est là où il faut
commencer à être préventif au niveau des
maladies en fin de compte le résultat
est totalement rassurant puisque je suis
normal organisé en partenariat avec
l'association insu libre cette journée
de dépistage et d'information a pour
vocation de lever le voile sur une
maladie qui touche de plus en plus de
personnes en france pour sa population
serait touchée par différentes formes de
diabète non traitées maladie peut avoir
des conséquences dramatiques
ce qui nous a alertés nous département
on peut être atteint du diabète sans le
savoir
donc rien que ça rien que dire cela
c'est déjà un constat il faut faire
quelque chose pour que l'on sache qu'on
est malade ou qu'on ne l'est pas voilà
donc mettre tout en oeuvre pour que tous
nos publics et tous les publics tous les
haut rhinoises et haut rhinois puisse un
moment donné se faire dépister pour
surveiller ou pas une maladie éventuel
les causes exactes du diabète reste
encore mal connue pourtant les
spécialistes ce stade quant à pointer
une alimentation trop riche et le manque
d'exercice comme des facteurs importants
en matière de santé comme souvent il
vaut mieux prévenir que guérir
c'est important effectivement de se
faire suivre donc de réaliser
régulièrement un examen de sang donc
c'est à discuter avec le médecin
traitant pour voir quelle est la
fréquence pour chacun d'entre nous en
fonction de nos trajets note de notre
situation
ensuite dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est tout simplement 20 suivre
adoptée on va dire une bonne hygiène de
vie donc une alimentation saine une
activité physique si c'est possible dans
la mesure des possibilités de chacun en
tout cas voilà et ses capacités
voilà c'est le meilleur moyen aussi de
prévenir l'obésité et le diabète
mulhouse centre médico-social fonderie
pour cette toute jeune fille aujourd'hui
ses rendez vous avec sa puéricultrice
croissance bois motricité la matinée est
consacrée à un bilan
les puéricultrices de la protection
maternelle et infantile suivent
développement des enfants mais conseille
surtout les parents c'est pour apporter
une aide d'une orientation parents et
puis pour que beaucoup d'enfants il
évolue bien dans un milieu adapté le
rôle parental et qu'elle est très
compliqué et du coup c'est parfois on
peut être un peu perdu et on a besoin
d'être régulier surtout sur ces choses
là il ya différentes possibilités du
coût des dents groupe plutôt
individuelle et c'est en fonction de
chacun ce qu'il a envie de de la manière
dont son envie d'aborder les choses 130
professionnels interviennent à la
protection maternelle infantile dans le
haut-rhin des médecins des sages-femmes
des puéricultrices des psychologues des
éducatrices de jeunes enfants des
assistantes sociales et du personnel
administratif
le service assure le très nombreuses
missions pendant et après la grossesse
mais aussi en matière d'accès à la
contraception
si on peut trouver les équipes de la pmi
dans les centres médico sociaux sur
l'ensemble du territoire
le gros de leurs missions s'effectuent
hors les murs il ya plein d'autres
actions qui sont menées horse ces
centres qui sont les actions qui sont
menées aux domiciles des parents au
domicile des parents parce que on a
besoin de les aider dans leur
environnement
on va voir aussi des articles l'assurons
avec les maternités
les puéricultrices des sages-femmes pour
aller régulièrement dans les maternités
un autre versant de notre activité c'est
la planification familiale
donc on a un travail d'information à
travail de consultation et un travail
d'accompagnement des femmes ou le maine
où dans nos centres ou en partenariat
avec les services de gynécologie 10 à 20
% des mamans et des bébés haut rhinois
sont suivis à un moment par la pmi si le
service cible en priorité des personnes
pouvant avoir des difficultés d'accès
aux soins
tous les parents sans exception peuvent
demander conseil toutes les mamans qui
sortent de maternité elles peuvent avoir
besoin d'avoir un conseil un soutien ça
peut être un soutien ponctuel ça peut
être un début d'un accompagnement plus
long
au cours des années de l'enfant puisque
notre service a en charge les enfants de
0 à 6 ans
et paysages à couper le souffle un
patrimoine hors du commun des activités
culturelles et sportives
c'est sur le haut rhin ne manque pas
d'atouts ce sont ceux là que le conseil
départemental a choisi de mettre en
avant dans cette vidéo pour attirer des
professionnels de santé dans les
territoires où l'on en manque mais à
l'hôtel du département pour lutter
contre la désertification médicale va
plus loin on lance un appel à l'ensemble
des médecins généralistes qui sortent
des études ou qui n'ont pas encore
terminé les études et qui veulent tester
un territoire des élus peuvent leur
proposer de les accueillir par le biais
d'un logement
l'époux zhu l'époux ou le conjoint que
tout simplement trouver un emploi
également on a des package possible et
on a des financements que l'on met en en
plus nous conseil départemental pour
l'accueil de ses personnels les secteurs
concernés sont kaysersberg ensisheim
guebwiller et dannemarie